to increase one's Consciousness or
awareness to achieve a state of
Enlightenment is to increase one's
capacity for that type of information
which is why at a certain point you can
comprehend all your previous lifetimes
what's happening with reincarnation is a
mix of free will and determination
determinism I should say law of
attraction in this universe applies not
just this one lifetime it applies also
to the cycle of reincarnation in general
So based off of of what we are doing in
this current life we are a vibrational
match to the next life you're standing
in a space where you're able to see all
these potential lifetimes you have
memory of the previous one you just came
out of and several more before then
you're looking to create expansion so
what is my path of expansion from
everything I've gained so far it is that
point of perspective that causes you to
choose into that next Incarnation but
you can only be a match to the ones
which are currently in your vibratory
Spectrum so
that has a lot to do with you know the
choices you've made in previous lives
and XYZ